yeah Robert so what is it like so you
start in the beginning of the day what's
it like yeah so normally I wake up 3:30
4 o'clock a.m. do a little paperwork
knock some emails out um go through the
birds luckily right now I got a
full-time farm hand this first time ever
so um I don't have to be up there as
much but we're going through them every
day you're you're checking for any type
of mortality making sure they all have
automatic feeder so there's one feed
line that runs continuously down the
barn 800 and some feet long so a feeder
that runs down the barn that they're all
housed in Yep they're housed in it's uh
they have plenty of room ample amount we
you know bioc is key so we we dress up
suit up go through dip pans make sure
nothing comes in from the barn that's
not supposed to be in there oh really
yeah yeah we're very to the niche we do
like Animal Welfare every year you know
we're we're really on top of our game
because you know this is our livelihood
this is why I feed my kid right with and
you know some sometimes commercial Farms
can they'll call it commercial Farms but
it's really just a small town guy you
know it's a family maybe running a dairy
operation maybe running cattle and then
they're also substituting some income
for other family members for for turkeys
okay so I can make the same I make the
same amount of money as if I was running
maybe 200 hit of cattle okay wow so with
the amount of turkeys you're running yes
and how many birds are you guys uh you
know how many birds are you guys dealing
with over there uh so roughly like
19,000 20 to 22,000 per flop and that's
two barns so okay so 19,000 per flock so
what does that mean so uh generally we
have a flock and it'll last uh 19 weeks
is to to a full grown bird and they go
to market okay okay and then uh
depending how it rotates you know you'll
have like four weeks down eight weeks
down depending when they're ready to
place you with more pts or more turkeys
from the Hatchery okay so it starts with
you get a batch of turkeys so you have
no turkeys at some point yeah yeah so
sometimes I'll have a downtime for four
weeks well we're cleaning turkey
okay you're just cleaning out the barns
yeah yeah so okay so then you get the
bats right yep um they come in fresh
shavings laying you know we spread out
brand new shavings and they're all
shaved out yeah we clean the poop belt
it's all nice nice clean pretty pretty
pretty ground strip club up in there son
nice nice lights okay so you get them in
and they are they scared are they
excited what do they seem like they're
ready to eat okay so they've done
traveled got there they're really happy
birds they're clucking they've been on
the road they're ready to chill out yeah
so we we load them in they come in um
it's nice and warm in there for them
because when they're younger they like
it up you know around the 80s to 100
depending how the age of the bird okay
so you guys have lamps and stuff in
there that keep them warm soan heaters
yeah we got propane heaters a lot
propane and uh so they're all in this
hat in uh at that point it's you already
bought them from a hatchery so they're
all in this Barn yeah okay so you have
them in this barn now how long until
till those birds until you guys you know
you pull that card on them you know low
them out and send them onto the market
uh 19 18 and a half to 19 weeks wow so
they're and then when they go out
they're you know averaging 40 to 45
pounds how well the feed conversion okay
so and that is you guys are feeding them
the whole time how often do you feed
them they eat non-stop they have they
have access to water and food the entire
time they're like my buddy Cory full
buff and will they eat uh and what are
they eating corn it's it's a corn
soybean and then sometimes wheat and
it's all natural we have our own
Hatchery so y'all ever go out there and
give them a little snack at night is
there any kind of a bedtime snack is
there anything where you're going to
sneak out there you feeling in a good
mood you're going to go out there and
hook them up no there's you like may you
want moon pie but they're like nah we're
good so they just like what they they're
real specific no they they really just
like that that feed that corn
soybean mix I mean that's pretty much it
they their water we have a water system
I mean they get in perfect pH every time
okay so like we're really really big on
their water so it's like a little Spa in
there they treat you know they got the
Heat going they got the food coming in
they're really living they're living
pretty large in there okay curtains go
down they get natural light they get to
see outside a little bit I mean they're
D they're safe from any type of
predators sounds like a detox I went to
one time honestly to be real honest yeah
yeah um now what about this so so so
then you go in there on your daily
routine you Cruise in there we Cruise in
there you have special you know you got
the gear on because you don't want how
detrimental is it if you bring in
something from the outside world so just
for instance you probably heard of AVM
flu oh yeah yeah so like back uh
2016 15 and 16 they had a huge outbreak
killed a million plus Birds Nationwide
damn which it it helped yeah you're talk
yeah yeah so it it you know we didn't
luckily hit it and I hate to prosper on
you know bad terms for other Farmers cuz
I hope we all get our you know rifle do
and everybody be is successful um but it
helped us out and bumped us up real high
and uh uh we did very well not having
that avien flu but it's literally if I
went outside stepped in some Goose crap
and that feal matter was on my shoe if I
stepped in that barn with the same
clothes I had on with that it would 100%
effect IM mortality
no way within like 3 days damn so
they're a real it's a real it's almost
like a they sound like almost like a
science not a science experiment but
they're like a real specific recipe if
you put in a little bit of something
that's not good it's going down yeah and
see like a they're real sensitive yeah
so other birds can affect other birds
same like you can't have chickens on a
turkey farm same I can't have turkeys on
chicken farm stuff that would mess with
a chicken will mess with a turkey oh
really
and it won't won't see them like the
geese that fly you know they're they're
just a carrier they they don't uh they
don't die from the Aven flu but they can
spread it to other birds and even if say
the damn it's like succession have you
seen that show yes no no I actually
haven't anyway so this is really cool so
so now you go in there you guys are kind
of like you you you you're careful what
you bring into the barn Y and you get in
there it's it's the early morning and
then what are you guys doing at that
point so we're going through making sure
you know none of the water lines are
broke there's no water leaks the Fe
feeds all properly Distributing through
the lines okay occasionally you'll have
a mortality one bird might just cro and
from what could have been anything just
anything heart liver you know just
sometimes you just you know you have so
many birds in there well not so many but
you'll have birds in there and they just
you know just like human life man out
here they no different if you were
raising for outside in the field you
know oh you could be jogging with your
buddy and he's dead just drop yeah same
thing with those dude Tom Tom just
dropped Tom number two like bro what's
up I ain't never the same some lose some
man and you don't know what's going on
they might have small beef going on in
there they you know occas they do fight
you know they'll occasionally rough up
each other you got to break them up will
they yeah yeah dude like No Nonsense
Keith Peters and baby you got to get in
there like Herb Dean right in between
them um how has the meat damn that's you
right there yeah damn this your first
wife yeah this is damn beautiful pretty
good actually when they're going out so
that's a good picture see feed Line's
raised everything's there lights are on
it's night time that's one of the
heavier birds that he probably weighed
close to I 46 47 pounds and this is only
a middle Tom right no this is a heavy
Tom that's big boys there that's see
they got little beards whatnot dude it's
really they're kind of beautiful I
didn't I guess I have not seen pictures
like this yeah they're nice pretty white
birds and uh really clean like I said
the that's why we do litter quality
we're we're in there tilling day-to-day
operation every week we go in there with
a tractor and a tiller to make sure the
you know the shavings get brought back
to the top everything stays nice for
their feet cuz if you if you got poor
litter quality and and poor poor life
these birds won't look like that they'll
be uh be really run down they'll have
burned pads on their feet from the
turkey turkey crap it'll burn their feet
so that's why we yeah that's why we make
sure everything's nice and nice and
clean so there are real sensitive animal
huh they can be yeah it's interesting
how they're tough and I don't know
turkeys are smart and dumb all at the
same time I guess just like me yeah me
too dude damn I didn't know it was
possible and then here we
are okay wow so you got the birds now
you guys and when they when they when
they do take when they do send them out
to harvest when they send them out
what's the process do they line them all
up and like just neck them out now this
will this'll probably be a little wild
we'll bring in 19 tractor trailers and
handload them on three guys they'll
bring them up and it's like a little
escalator takes them right up and they
pick one up put them in the cage load
the cage up truck goes down turns back
around they can load a truck up in like
35 minutes and they gasing them well
they take them back to the processing
facility and that's they I think they
use like a CO2 base and they'll just put
them to sleep then uh they're cutting
them up really sing them up conveyor
belt and so they put the meat to they
just put them to sleep so they're not
shooting them it's not like a bullet or
anything no no yeah so like on the farm
they you got two options for your Animal
Welfare you can either they have like a
bolt gun like a cap gun you'll hit them
in the back of the head with it and
they'll just take them right out or some
Farmers rig up like a little box with
CO2 and they'll they'll put them in and
that way they go night just go to sleep
and then you put them in the compost and
then we compost the birds for uh crop
rotation we'll put them on fields and
stuff oh so you they'll become a
fertilizer almost yeah we'll create
fertilizer y all natural so you so you
guys don't do the actual uh so the
killing isn't actually done by you guys
it's shipped that it's like outsourced
yeah so so now I will you know Dam Bugsy
seagull out there just rolls up huh yeah
so we will kill birds and I ones I have
to call I I'll I'll pull the meat out
for friends and family cut the breast
meat I got some pictures I'll give you
guys and you can show them the size of
the breast and stuff like that but damn
yeah man constant now what about this
guy is a question right here this
Italian guy all
right what's up Theo what's up turkey
farmer got a question man
what's up with the free range and the
natural and the question organic and the
regular is that just a farce is it the
real deal what are you buying at the
stores thanks that's that's a good
question yeah it's a great question man
yeah what is it what how do they divide
that up what do you guys have to do do
you guys have to so so if it's a like
the other Farms are more like The
Organic Farms or antibiotic free that's
uh it's heavily regulated so you got a
lot more paperwork and and actually like
to be an organic turkey it has to come
for organic female so all those the
closest organic female to us I believe
is in Pennsylvania so we have contract
Farms NPA that grows grows that
particular Bird Okay so so so a lot of
what goes in I heard this I have a
friend that works for like a meat
company yeah called cow or something I
think and uh but it's K right and he
sent me some fancy meat one time and
it's good but you know it's still
expensive but um um he was saying that
what determines grass fet it's just uh
it's certain like really regulations do
even really have to do sometimes with
what they're eating It's just sometimes
where they live at things like that what
uh so what's that like for you guys so
you have the different different level
so like a uh Au or whatever they call it
it's antibiotic free the only difference
in between that is if say a bird gets
like a common cold or something you
wouldn't be able to treat it with like r
pen or penicillin for like one or two
days and everything's done very properly
with a vet you know we have a vet that
checks the bird it's just a crazy uh
industry but they they make sure they've
really went and stepped you know from
what it used to be to now it's it's it's
by the book everything's clean and done
professionally but so was it it used to
be the it used to be this the damn Dark
Art I from from what I hear back in
we've been doing it since ' 89 and it's
been fairly consistent all the way up
it's just you know more regulations and
we we we're wan to stay on top of
everything
yeah um but for like a a free range bird
so all they'll do is they'll take my
barn build doors and then the doors will
open and then they can go out in a
fenced in area Okay um sometimes they
don't even go out like my buddy grows uh
free range they yeah they free uh free
range chickens same thing he spent all
this money they leave the doors open the
birds are inside where it's nice and
safe anyway if it's sunny they might
come out for a little bit check up and
then they see a Hulk or something they I
tell it back in yeah maybe Andy D FR
sneaks out at night or one of them or
one of them government geese drop a turd
down there put them all
out hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this
one